Grisly gore-fests, dance routines… and Iron
Man doing laundry? Even the best movies shed
a scene or two in the cutting room — and
these sci-fi classics are no exception.
One of the most celebrated science fiction
movies of the early '80s, Star Trek II:
The Wrath of Khan may have saved the franchise
after the disappointment of the first movie
a few years earlier. But it almost included a
subplot that could have hurt its critical success.
"Khaaaan!"
In addition to a well-known deleted
scene involving Scotty's nephew,
who is killed after Khan's initial attack
on the Enterprise, the movie also cut out
an entire character: Khan's infant
son. In early versions of the movie,
the baby is introduced when Chekov and Captain
Terrell are searching Khan's ship, the Botany Bay.
The child would later appear with Khan aboard
the USS Reliant; in another deleted scene,
he dies when Khan accidentally activates the
Genesis device. Considering that the studio
decided to add a more positive ending late
in production, it could be that they felt the
death of Scotty's nephew and Khan's infant son
seemed a bit grim for a PG-rated sci-fi family
film. Images of Khan's son were revealed for the
first time in a 1982 issue of Starblazer Magazine,
but full footage of the scenes in
question have never been released.
Basically all movies end up having a few scenes
cut here and there — in the case of Event Horizon,
however, there's actually an entirely different
cut that has been lost to time. This version of
the film reportedly runs over two solid hours,
as opposed to the 95-minute theatrical release,
and includes far more gore. Tragically,
the studio didn't feel that the original
footage was worth keeping and much of
it has never seen the light of day.
Some excised moments include Captain
Miller discovering a loose tooth in a
corridor — apparently the remains of a former
crewman. Most of the deleted moments, however,
were extended versions of existing scenes that
were far more grisly than the studio or test
audiences could handle. A few of these managed to
survive, and a canister containing the original
film was discovered in an old Transylvania salt
mine. They eventually made their way onto a
later DVD release in a raw, unfinished form. Not
all of the deleted sequences could be restored,
though, as the newly-discovered film
was in poor condition when it was found.
Director David Cronenberg made a name
for himself as the go-to filmmaker for
body horror thanks to early cult classics
such as Videodrome and Scanners. In 1985,
he was given the task of remaking the '50s B-movie
The Fly. With Jeff Goldblum in the title role,
Cronenberg crafted one of the most gruesome
mainstream science fiction movies ever made.
"You look bad. You smell bad."
"Never been much of a bather."
But, if it hadn't been cut,
one scene in particular would have made
the whole film even harder to stomach.
The scene in question takes place after Seth
Brundle has begun his transformation. Looking
for a way to reverse the effects, Brundle thinks
he's found the answer, and proceeds to test out
an experimental procedure on a baboon and a cat.
However, the process inadvertently amalgamates the
two animals, and Brundle is forced to beat it to
death to spare it the agony of its own existence.
This moment was actually included
in early UK screenings of the film,
but movie-goers were so horrified that the studio
chose to cut it for wide release. It wasn't until
the film's 20th anniversary that it turned up
again, this time on a deluxe Blu-ray release.
There's no end to the number of great deleted
scenes in the Marvel Cinematic Universe. Most
of them have found their way out of the vault in
one form or another, and Marvel loves including
as many as possible on their home video releases.
Nevertheless, for 2008's Iron Man, some deleted
scenes will never be released — not if Kevin
Feige has anything to say about it, that is.
In an interview with Screen Rant, Marvel
executive producer Jeremy Latcham revealed
some deleted scenes were deemed so atrocious
that they'll never be made public. One of them
sees Tony Stark helping prison guard
Abu do some chores. Latcham revealed:
"Tony is doing laundry for the captors, but
he's really breaking the washing machine
and stealing parts from it to build the
Mark 1 suit. It's so absurd. It's wild."
The scene was apparently so poorly made that
studio boss Feige never wants
it shown. Latcham continued:
"I remember Kevin saying to me in 2012, [...] 'We
can never put out Abu doing laundry. People will
know we don't know what we're doing. It'll
be embarrassing if they see these scenes.'"
Starship Troopers is a sci-fi action classic from
1997 — and, in some ways, it's also a romance. The
love quadrangle between Rico, Carmen, Zander,
and Dizzy makes up a major part of the film,
especially in its early stages. Yet, if
director Paul Verhoeven had gotten his way,
the movie would have had an even greater emphasis
on the romantic angle of the story. In the end,
much of it wound up deleted from the film after
test audiences didn't react well to the subplot.
Some of the scenes cut include a moment in
which Carmen deflects Rico's sexual advances,
as well as a farewell scene where it becomes clear
that their relationship is somewhat forbidden.
In one later scene, after surviving a deadly
attack, Zander tells Carmen that he loves her,
helping to reinforce that new relationship
in a way the final film never does.
The last deleted scene comes right
at the end of the film. We'd seen
the death of Dizzy and Zander earlier on, and
audiences may have wondered what that meant
for Johnny and Carmen's relationship.
Well, this scene answers that question,
as the pair share a passionate
kiss just before the credits roll.
If you're looking for the best movie about
a robot cop, well, you're not gonna do much
better than RoboCop. Die-hard fans consider it
the perfect '80s action movie, with not a moment
wasted in capturing the excitement of mortally
wounded cop Alex Murphy as he's transformed into
the heroic cyborg known as RoboCop. As it turned
out, finding perfection involved trimming a few
moments from the original script, one of which
saw the hero cop returning to his own grave.
Though it wasn't filmed, this scene was
included in both the novelization and
the movie's Marvel Comics adaptation.
And when it came time for a sequel,
RoboCop 2, director Irvin Kershner
decided to make it happen. This time,
the sequence was intended to be part of an early
moment carrying over from the first film's end,
when RoboCop embraces his identity as Alex
Murphy. Despite all the effort put into making
the scene a reality, however, the graveyard
visit didn't make it into this movie either.
Directed by the legendary Stanley Kubrick,
2001: A Space Odyssey is one of the seminal
works in the sci-fi genre. It reshaped science
fiction with a mix of thought-provoking drama,
nail-biting suspense, and
state-of-the-art special effects.
"Open the pod bay doors, Hal."
"I'm sorry, Dave. I'm afraid I can't do that."
For years, rumors have claimed that Kubrick
trimmed some 20 minutes of footage from 2001,
and we finally got confirmation when reels from
the film were discovered in, of all places,
another salt mine. These scenes aren't exactly the
most pivotal, but they do serve to flesh out the
finer details of the mission to Jupiter. Some of
the footage includes extended sequences of Frank
Poole jogging, as well as an alternate version
of the iconic opening sequence. One deleted scene
sees HAL 9000 ending the radio communication
between the Discovery and Poole's pod not long
before he's killed, which means a later exchange
between Dave and HAL makes a little more sense.
Set in the 23rd century, The Fifth Element
introduces Milla Jovovich as Leeloo,
a woman believed by an order of ancient monks
to be the key to defeating a cosmic evil.
One of The Fifth Element's most intriguing deleted
scenes takes place when Dallas is ferrying Leeloo
and the monk Cornelius to the airport. There, they
would have encountered a group of striking alien
garbage collectors taking part in a fight with
local police. Remnants of this scene can be found
in the final cut, as the airport itself is filled
with garbage piled meters high that is never
adequately explained — the airport attendant only
briefly apologizes for "the mess." Years later,
a behind-the-scenes featurette on the movie's
4K UHD Blu-ray chronicled this lost moment.
The last film in the franchise to
feature the cast of The Next Generation,
the 2002 box office dud Star Trek: Nemesis was
met with a critical drubbing on its release.
Critics claimed the movie was dull,
lifeless, and lacking in the charm of
the TV series. But quite a few deleted scenes
would have gone a long way to keeping what was
lost — mostly smaller character moments between
the likes of Captain Picard, Commander Riker,
and Dr. Crusher. While fans have known about
some of these deleted scenes for decades,
one recently surfaced that was never
included on any home video release.
This scene comes after Data's death. Aboard
the Enterprise, which remains under repair,
we find Worf and Geordi going through their
late comrade's quarters. At one point,
Data's cat, Spot, leaps into Worf's arms, who
reluctantly adopts the feline as his own. Cut
from the film's initial DVD release despite
the inclusion of other deleted moments,
this scene has since surfaced
online in low resolution.
The biggest sci-fi movie of the '90s,
Independence Day was a watershed flick
that forever changed the summer blockbuster.
The movie isn't without its plot holes,
however; many fans have raised questions
about the virus created by David Levinson,
which he eventually uses to
take down the alien mothership.
"Welcome to Earth."
Some have wondered how his terrestrial
laptop could so easily interface with
technology from another world, while
others have scratched their heads at
how he even knew how to take down
their computer system at all.
A deleted scene included on the film's 20th
anniversary home video release would have
answered one of those questions. In this
scene, Levinson lays out his plan to crash
the alien computer network in more detail
while he's given a tour of the captured
alien ship by Dr. Brackish Okun. While Okun
admits they have very little idea as to how
the alien technology works, Levinson
deduces that a sequential repeating
pattern they've discovered is actually a code
that they're using to coordinate their ships.
It might not be the most air-tight
explanation, but it offers at least a
slightly better explanation as to how
Levinson brought down those aliens.
Before the likes of Independence Day and Star
Wars turned the genre into blockbuster fare,
science fiction films were thoughtful,
talky dramas — and The Day the Earth
Stood Still was one of the very best. In
this eerie tale, an alien visitor named
Klaatu arrives with a dire message for
Earth's leaders — one that he will not
reveal until they can all gather together
peacefully. Escaping government custody,
Klaatu tries to blend in with humanity in order to
learn why they are so distrustful of one another.
But there's one scene cut from the film that most
of the movie's fans have probably never seen.
In the film, a detective arrives to
take Klaatu to see a local scientist,
Professor Barnhardt. In the original script,
the detective first takes him to the police
station for questioning. While there, a local
man is brought in seriously injured, and it's
revealed that the man was attacked after he was
mistaken for Klaatu. Feeling a sense of guilt,
but also confusion as to why people would attack
a stranger in such a manner, Klaatu begs for the
police to take him straight to Barnhardt. Though
a brief scene, it's one that adds important
context to Klaatu's journey, demonstrating
both his empathy and humanity's folly.
Blade Runner is pretty much a deleted scene
bonanza. Over the years, most of the scenes
dropped from the original release have found
their way into a multitude of different cuts,
including the workprint cut, the director's
cut, and the so-called "Final Cut."
"Like tears… in rain."
Yet none of these versions include the
alternate, deleted opening scene. That's
because it was never actually filmed; in fact,
it was only revealed years after the fact in a
series of storyboards, first published in
Future Noir: The Making of Blade Runner.
In the alternate first scene, Detective
Rick Deckard is seen landing his spinner
on a desolate road. He exits the flying car
and enters an empty home, where he notices
that there is still a pot of soup boiling on
the stove. As he listlessly stirs the soup,
a large, hulking man walks in — and Deckard
immediately shoots him dead. He then rips out
a piece of his jaw, revealing the man to be
a replicant, and takes off in his spinner.
If all of this sounds familiar, it should.
That's because this original opening was
used as the intro to the sequel, Blade Runner
2049, which was released nearly 40 years later.
Featuring some of the most jaw-dropping action
sequences in movie history, Jurassic Park is a
true blockbuster adventure in every way. Steven
Spielberg's classic left indelible images etched
into the minds of countless movie-goers: whether
it's the first sight of the brontosauruses or
the clicking talons of the velociraptor on that
cold kitchen floor. No matter how many memorable
moments the movie boasts, however, there are
still more that didn't make it into the film.
One deleted action sequence would have
seen Alan Grant, Tim, and Lex stumble upon
a sleeping Tyrannosaurus rex while roaming the
jungle. After sneaking past the beast without
drawing its attention, they make their way to a
nearby structure where they are able to grab an
inflatable raft from storage. They take off down
the river — but, just when the trio thinks they're
in the clear, the T-Rex bursts out from behind
the trees and tears after them. It doesn't seem
as if this sequence was ever filmed, sadly,
and today it exists only in storyboard form.
"We got one!"
A supernatural comedy with a pair of former SNL
stars leading the way, Ghostbusters defied the
odds to become a pop culture icon. The movie
quickly inspired a diehard group of fans who,
for decades, only had a pair of films to pour
over. So you can imagine the excitement when,
in 2017, new footage from the original movie
was discovered — including some hilarious
deleted scenes. Found in the personal
collection of director Ivan Reitman,
the reels' discovery caused quite
a stir among Ghostbusters fans.
One of these scenes was "Fort Detmerring," a
long-known but never-seen moment in which Ray
Stantz has a sexual encounter with a ghost. In
the final film, remnants of this scene are shown
in a montage, but the full sequence has never been
revealed. It opens with the Ecto-1 arriving at the
fort, and the team exploring the grounds. Ray puts
on an old naval uniform he finds and lays down
in a bed before the ghost of a beautiful woman
enters the room. Following a brief unseen sex act
that somehow did manage to make it into the final
movie, Winston is seen knocking on the door to the
room, wondering what's going on. Given the fact
that the most risque portion of the scene actually
wound up in the theatrical cut, it's likely that
the full extended scene was simply cut for time.
The culmination of a decade of stories,
Avengers: Infinity War brought together
just about every character in the MCU to
battle Thanos, the big bad who wanted to
erase half of all life in the universe.
With such a broad, sweeping story to tell,
Infinity War had a lot to pack in, and some
reviewers inevitably felt it was a little long
and overstuffed. But it could have been worse:
According to Thanos' creator, Jim Starlin,
the original plan was actually to open the movie
with an additional 45-minute action sequence.
Instead of beginning with
an attack on Thor's ship,
Infinity War would have begun with Thanos'
assault on the planet Xandar. He would have
decimated the entire planet in
his search for the power stone,
which is held under protection by the Nova Corps.
In an interview with Collider, Starlin explained:
"There was a whole sequence of him
getting the first gem and they had
to cut that out. They shot it, but they
never wanted to spend the money on the
effects and they didn't want the movie
to be as long as the second one was."
Starlin seems to feel that the filmmakers
may have regretted their decision. He added:
"They didn't realize it was going
to be quite the hit it was."
Another '80s icon, Back to the Future sends
Michael J. Fox's Marty McFly hurtling back
to the '50s. Marty soon discovers
that his father is a total dweeb,
and when his mother falls in love with him,
he's forced to help his dad get the girl to
save his own existence. The film hammers
home what a loser George is by showing him
being bullied by tough guy Biff — but one
deleted scene makes George look even worse.
"Great Scott!"
During the Enchantment Under the Sea dance at the
climax of the movie, George is preparing to go
through with his plan to "rescue" Lorraine from a
staged encounter with Marty. Nervous about acting
at the right moment, he seeks out a phone booth
and calls the operator to get the time, only to be
locked inside by Mark, the redheaded class clown
who later cuts into his dance with Lorraine. With
a prop trident holding the door closed, George
is then discovered by Principal Strickland, who
scolds him for being a slacker… but doesn't let
him out. Likely cut for time or pacing reasons,
this sequence actually explains why George
didn't make it to the car in time to stop Marty.
Most films these days include plenty of deleted
scenes once they make their way to home video.
Fans love to go over the various bits
of the movie they never got to see,
but they're typically superfluous moments and it's
usually easy to understand why they were removed.
Sometimes, though, there's a scene that leaves
you wondering why it wasn't in the movie — and
that's the case with a deleted scene from Rian
Johnson's 2012 sci-fi action movie Looper.
The film stars Bruce Willis as Joe, an aging
hitman who uses time travel to dispose of his
targets. When he's due for retirement and his
superiors send him back in time to be killed by
his younger self, old Joe manages to escape.
At one point, young Joe hides out at a house
belonging to a woman named Sara — and, soon after
he arrives, a mafia thug shows up looking for him.
After a tense, drawn-out search of the house, Sara
gives the goon a tour of the basement where Joe
is hiding, and we're sure it's going to lead to a
showdown. The suspense is palpable as the mobster
stalks the room… only for us to realize that Joe
is hiding beneath the floor, where he is able
to escape notice. The choice to leave out this
incredibly tense scene is a real head scratcher.
Following Star Trek: Nemesis, the
Star Trek franchise took a hiatus
from the big screen — but it came roaring
back with a new look in J.J. Abrams' 2009
reboot. The sequel to that movie, Star Trek
Into Darkness, centered once again on Khan,
this time played by Sherlock
star Benedict Cumberbatch,
who is an even more ruthless and cunning version
of the villain than that seen in Wrath of Khan.
"Khaaaaan!"
This time around, he is revealed to have been
manipulated by a secret black ops division
of Starfleet called Section 31, led by Admiral
Marcus. While the final film doesn't reveal the
truth about who is manipulating him until later,
an early deleted scene almost gives it away.
This moment comes in the form of a video
communication to Marcus from Thomas Harewood,
who is about to detonate a bomb in London at
Khan's behest. The scene shows Marcus receiving
the transmission in his office, with Harewood
informing him that the impending destruction will
be a message from Khan. Ultimately, though,
producers cut the scene because it revealed
a little too much about the players involved. In
the film's commentary, editor Mary Jo Markey said:
"We felt that it was very important
not to introduce the admiral in any
way or tip our hand about who he
would become later on in the film,.
We realized to hold him back for a
long time would be more shocking."
The MCU is littered with juicy deleted scenes,
but few are as jaw-dropping as one moment cut
from Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness. The film sees Stephen Strange
face off against Wanda Maximoff, who has turned
twisted and vengeful after losing Vision and her
children. Determined to find an alternate reality
where she and her family can live in peace,
Wanda traverses the multiverse itself — and
basically slaughters everyone in her path.
Multiverse of Madness has Wanda taking the
proverbial ax to the likes of Mr. Fantastic,
Professor Charles Xavier, and Black Bolt, but
a deleted scene further shows just how vicious
she has really become. Not long after the
movie's release, one of the film's artists,
Jimmy Simser, released storyboards depicting
the moment when Scarlet Witch arrives at
Kamar Taj to get her hands on America
Chavez. In this unseen version, though,
Wanda isn't alone — as she brings with
her the decapitated head of Baron Mordo.
1989's Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure is a
weird and wild story that sees the two friends
enlist famous faces from history to help them get
a passing grade in school to save the future. Over
the years, a number of deleted scenes from
the movie have cropped up here and there,
and in 2020, one of the film's stars dug
into the vault to reveal yet another.
"Excellent!"
Posting on X, formerly known as Twitter, Alex
Winter showed off images of a sequence early
in the film in which Bill and Ted make their way
home from school. The sequence would have included
a bizarre musical number that fans ultimately
never got to see. Winter told Rolling Stone:
"The opening was an almost surreal rock
number where Keanu and I are at a bus
stop waiting for the school bus in the
morning and we start to air-guitar and
rock out. And it turned into a whole
dance routine. Then it ends up with us
kind of getting into a skirmish with the
school jocks and you meet our characters
that way. All of that stuff was shot
and none of it made it into the film."
A box office juggernaut, E.T. the
Extra-Terrestrial was nominated
for nine Academy Awards including
best picture and best director;
it won best original score and three additional
technical awards. The story of a strange alien
visitor who is befriended by a pair of
young children named Elliott and Gertie,
E.T. remains one of the most beloved family
movies of all time. Yet, a few deleted scenes
that have shown up over the years might
have totally changed the tone of the film.
In addition to a comedic moment that didn't
make the cut because the E.T. puppet just wasn't
convincing enough, there's one other scene
that seems awfully out of place in a movie
aimed at kids and families. Popping up decades
later thanks to some behind-the-scenes stills,
it shows Elliott's mother Mary
lying face down but topless,
asleep in bed late at night. As she slumbers,
the alien creeps into her bedroom and silently
observes her. Though probably intended to show
E.T. learning about humans, the images give off
a very unsettling vibe — one that might well
have disturbed the families in the audience.